libros infantiles cubiertos de polvo y
ventanas rotas es lo que queda de este
dormitorio en una zona Residencial de
nipro en el centro de Ucrania ataques
rusos con misiles dejaron varios civiles
muertos y heridos en diferentes ciudades
se trata de los primeros ataques aéreos
a gran escala en dos meses el gobernador
de Nitro hace un balance lo ocurrido en
esta localidad murió gente un niño de 2
años y su madre de 32 años murieron
cuatro personas resultaron heridas dos
de ellas fueron ingresadas en el
hospital
a 400 kilómetros de Nitro en Umán los
misiles destruyeron este conjunto de
apartamentos
[Música]
sergi lubitsky observa su hogar de ruido
no tengo lugar para vivir vecinos se han
ido no queda nadie en el noveno piso
vivía una anciana su hija y dos nietos
se han ido
un hombre con su hijo vivía en el octavo
piso
una mujer con su hija en El séptimo piso
se han ido no hay nadie vivo en toda la
manzana
el ministro del interior visitó la zona
y supervisó las operaciones de rescate
alrededor de 300 personas trabajan en el
sitio incluidos policías y servicios
públicos
en la línea del frente las tropas
ucranianas se preparan para la
contraofensiva
en término generales estamos listos si
es la voluntad de Dios el clima y la
decisión de los comandantes lo haremos
los tanques leopardos y Challenger de
sus aliados internacionales ya fueron
recibidos sin embargo kiev no cree que
los abrams de Estados Unidos lleguen a
tiempo para la contraofensiva